with an example of a flat character
versus a more three-dimensional
characters like even just in the
description of something
just give me one sentence that flat
versus one that's right
tells you volume run in one sentence
right so you see this a lot I mean this
is more about cliche writing so you get
like a character description well you
know I read this all the time you know
she's beautiful or handsome you know
it's the same help me I said it was
right I mean no it's the same old have
you've seen the hundred times you know
she's going to be little more creative
there's a lot of creativity and
originality - I think originality comes
from being curious because the more
curious you are about something more you
know about something and so the more you
can avoid copying some things right it's
I think the people who write cliche what
cliche writing is because they don't
know what's been done before so they go
to them it's new so they go oh they
think it's good but people who know and
they've seen it a hundred times because
they're curious I will say it's cliche
because they've seen it a hundred times
for character description of somebody
that you know his his eyes sparkled or
mems and said that yeah right
location thing right they just don't
bother to go deeper you know what I mean
you got to be original I mean that's
another thing originality is very
important you know because if you read
the same thing over and over are you
just gonna not it's not gonna respond to
it you know so really that is actually
the bane of the writers existence
especially the screenwriter to come up
with something new I mean when you think
about I think in in the the second
edition of the 101 habits bill marsilii
one of the one of the screenwriters
there talks about doing the 20s so for
him like everything that he thinks about
any event any scene character whatever
he thinks of kind of listing 20
different ways of doing it like if it's
like a you talk about the meet-cute
writing in romantic comedy how people
meet in a cute way
well he's going to do 20 different
thoughts about it okay the kameez did
because it did I mean you have to do he
does 20 because the the first two or
three or five of them will be cliches
will be things that you know your
automatic going to think about them
because they're the most famous ones or
them
that we've seen under time but going
deeper and he forces himself to go
deeper that's where you get D creativity
and originality and eventually when you
reach that past of 10 or 12 15 all the
way up to 20 you'll start getting some
really original ways because you force
yourself and so that that's what the
writer needs to do you got to force
yourself to go deeper in order to create
some original writing alright so getting
all that number one and through five is
probably just totally yeah you just
write as a game it's a tip that he uses
of the you know habit of creativity to
just do the 24 anything you know 20
different ways to rob a bank 20
different ways to to say I love you 20
different ways to break up with someone
so in different ways to kill someone I
mean there's all these things that
you've seen a hundred times and when you
see it over and over you go you know
you're you go cool you know because
you've seen it under time and it's only
the really the movies that break out
stories the stories of Uruk are the ones
that are kind of truly original right so
let's take the movie green card
okay Gerard Depardieu and Amy McDowell
so that that would be probably further
down the list I would think a movie
night they wanted to it was an
interesting I mean that's the thing
that's what I love about romantic
comedies is that it's such a set story
in terms of shape in terms of structure
in terms of boy gets girl you know vice
versa girl gets boy loses loses boy gets
Capone it's the same thing all romantic
comedies are the same literally but the
ones that I think are you know that that
we pay attention to will become
successful the ones that have a unique
angle to it it's that hook right same
thing only different that only different
is the ones like green card or any other
you know Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind or even the breakup which
is like okay it's romantic comedy where
it's like they break up as opposed to
you know getting together it's like it's
so whenever you come up with a unique
angle to that story that we all know the
better for you that's where we
generality originality comes in you know
so and it gets harder and harder because
you know the more
the more the more romantic companies
there is the harder it is to come up
with something new so you know that's
what
you